to our 11 minute movie waste time on
some kind of Goonies neverending story
kid in the Attic book on a night much
like this on a night much like this
cliche movie saves a few bucks by using
b-roll from The Mummy and 300 franchises
for the flashback the freemasons among
our founding fathers left us Clues like
these the founding fathers spent
centuries protecting the treasure but
let's put clues on our money because
what foreigner would ever see us money
that's speaking to us through these you
mean laughing at us there's pretty much
no way he heard that also Christopher
Plummer is playing John Boyd's dad and
he's like nine years older than Jon
Voight Sean Bean isn't dying in this
scene while the Chaplin regard this
barrel is there any reason to believe he
was guarding it the ship has been tossed
around all over the place and the
captain managed to stay in the exact
position he was in when he died and I
thought you said that the treasure would
be on the shot I said it could be this
guy bankrolled this expedition without
fully understanding it I'm gonna be a
villain later face mr. Matlack can't
offend it's a riddle Ben's team is
befuddled that a secret society that
left puzzling clues and vague riddles
would leave another riddle to solve mr.
Matlack can't offend Gees with the clues
of Matlack and fifty-five in iron pen
and historian like gates should have
thought Declaration of Independence
almost immediately when you're going to
be as a hindrance in redcoats you know
it's incredibly convenient that this
ship had all this gunpowder but
considering the conditions in which it
was kept for a century or more the cold
conditions of the Arctic it's amazing it
still burns Ben and Riley survived this
explosion because reasons Sean Bean
steals the Sean Bean from Goldeneye and
doesn't make sure the hero is dead and
how did they survive well by climbing
further down into the bowels of the ship
so even more snow and debris and could
fall on top of them harmlessly is it
really so hard to believe that someone's
gonna try to steal the Declaration of
Independence yes yes it is while waiting
to tip off the museum chick about the
possible declaration theft Ben just
happens to spy a brochure to the perfect
declaration stealing type event when a
long train of abuses usurpations gates
recites passages from the Declaration of
Independence to justify stealing the
Declaration of Independence
John Hancock was a dick to space
shine upon us hey let's go to the
Lincoln Memorial to continue talking
about this the only way to protect the
declaration is to steal are you fucking
kidding me tell the FBI and then tell
them who he is then sit back and watch
if he steals it fine they know exactly
who has it and they will find him if he
doesn't problem solved but in no way in
the realm of common sense do you
actually have to steal it in order to
protect it it's stealing a National
Monument it's not like that at all it's
more like stealing a painting from a
museum and come on like that's never
been done before
best time for us or Ian to Stila would
be during the gala 70th anniversary gala
just happens to coincide with Ben's
treasure hunting plans when the guards
are distracted by the VIPs then talks
about the security of an event he has
never attended and the internal workings
of a preservation he has never witnessed
and presented as artifacts also the
museum that has temperature sensors and
bulletproof glass protecting the
document just quits giving all fucks
about security when its document
cleaning time that totally makes sense
Lingala this might be possible eight
said there would be much less security
which is presumably still a significant
amount of security but nervous Riley
suddenly changes his mind - this is so
doable now restricted important power
room is unlocked and completely
unrestricted damn it's like they want
someone to try and steal the document
publishing all this information about
the encasement and security features
there's a green laser getting shot at
the Declaration of Independence and no
one notices it so Ben went through
security pulling off his tool belt and
that's it but he's got a watch on -
how'd he get through the metal detector
with that but here's to the man who did
what was considered wrong in order to do
what they knew was right what they knew
was right dude might as well just say
I'm gonna steal the Declaration tonight
elf Khafre Valley Forge oh come on
high-tech security systems at the
National Archives are using passwords
tantamount to password Valley Forge I
don't have that on my computer sorry for
sure pristine old horse also did the
computer genius not program his anagram
software to take keys being used
multiple times into account wait Riley's
the one who caused the declaration to be
taken downstairs for a check-up when he
put the temperature sensors so how the
hell whirring and crew planning to get
it how the hell did they even know to
end their elaborate break-in path at the
downstairs sensor tracking room do you
have a Paul Brown
no not here Museum chick gets curious
because of course gates had to act all
weird and give her a cryptic apology
otherwise this doesn't happen but I
guess then we wouldn't have much of a
movie or a shoehorn romantic subplot so
whatever wait just a goddamn minute you
plan this high-tech heist for weeks down
to the smallest detail and you're using
a fake name but you brought your wallet
with you
you cannot present Ben gates as this
uber genius and then hinge the entire
plot of the film on him doing something
so mind-numbingly stupid as to bring his
own credit card which of course he ends
up having to use there's clearly a car
in this far lane next to the bus but
then the van veers over there to avoid
the bus and voila magic disappearing car
also not Nicolas Cage is not Nicolas
Cage this twangy real desired object was
replaced with a fake wind cliche also
what a stroke of luck that Ben was
trying to hide from Abigail went into
this souvenir shop and then ended up
buying an extra declaration after this
hilarious exchange with the register
girl
we got a tip several days ago that
someone was going to steal the
Declaration of Independence we didn't
find the information credible how about
now you probably also got a tip that
Nazi zombie hookers from space hell
we're gonna land in Wichita this week
seriously every gonna give the FBI agent
grief over this the tip was to people
walking into an office with a crazy
story and no evidence this website tells
us that Ben Franklin wrote the letters
in 1722 when he was 15 but he was born
in 1706 and he would have had to be 16
especially since it was born in January
Ben Franklin was only 15 years old he
secretly wrote 14 letters to his
brothers newspaper which just so happen
to have a key to the treasure who
entrust treasure clues to a 15 year old
especially someone who wasn't exactly
rich famous or in any way special at the
time treasures the cake is a lie am i
right
also mail main character doesn't get
along with his father cliche guy who
respects the Declaration enough to steal
it and had set up a full chemical
cleaning room to run tests on it decides
forget let's just put lemon juice on
that and someone who's trained to handle
antique documents is gonna do it what
the lemon juice method I'm not really
sure it matters who has more expertise
using the actual laboratory methods so
Dad where are the letters
even though Ben and his dad haven't
spoken in some time it's amazing that an
ace historian like him somehow missed a
big news story that his dad donated the
letters to the Franklin Institute I
donated them to the Franklin Institute
in Philadelphia but don't worry we can
still google them right there is no
treasure I wasted 20 years of my life
did you happen to have a declaration of
independent cipher during those 20 years
you had virtually no clues
your so-called search what the hell were
you using for mr. case we'll find your
car and your son and we definitely won't
question you any further about being an
accomplice despite all the
circumstantial evidence and your shifty
behavior in case you confused it with
Philadelphia El Salvador so here's where
n decided to go to Philadelphia to check
out the silence do-good letters without
knowing once on the back of the
Declaration of Independence or why the
letters matter but thanks to sheer crazy
amazing timing he's here the same time
Ben is and we'll luck his way into the
knowledge he needs last one okay
last one you're writing all this down on
paper right he doesn't need to memorize
these codes so why not just write the
whole thing down and get all the answers
at once the whole reason this is done is
so Ian can catch up and it's totally Dom
Riley is addicted kids for the sake of
cute movie moments clothing stores will
now have side by side co-ed dressing
rooms with a hilarious lack of privacy
222 what time is it now almost 3:00 what
I know is that daylight savings wasn't
established until World War one okay
great an amazing fact about daylight
savings time makes it so they don't have
to wait another day to find out what
happened to 222 at the Liberty Bell
problem is the picture of Independence
Hall on the back of the $100 bill didn't
show up until 1928 long after World War
one do you actually know who the first
person to suggest daylight savings was
did Benjamin Franklin also use the
pseudonym George Vernon Hudson topless
jokes
Liberty Bell an independent or bad guy
crew solves the riddle in seconds with
only the last four letters Independence
Hall has no camera system in place to
monitor and protect it also security
mistakes 324 for 20 and is nowhere to be
found during Ben's easy access to the
clock tower oh and not for this reading
ly sunny day these guys would be fucked
if there's a brick with a big honking
Freemason symbol on it you really don't
need to be there at the perfect time you
could pretty much figure this out just
by knowing how the Sun moves and where
it would normally be at the right time
walk down and find this symbol and be on
your way how did they not pass Abigail
and Riley on their way down
Ian doesn't even take one look at the
Bell he just walks over to the place
where you can see the shadow even though
he has no clue that's important also we
can have a I hope Ben isn't still down
there moment there is no need to unroll
this thing right here right now or to
look at the back of it while inside a
public place they could easily go
somewhere safe to do this but they vote
for idiocy in the middle of using the
magic Ben Franklin spectacles to look at
the hidden message on the Declaration of
Independence inside the home where it
was signed notorious history geek
Benjamin Gates manages to look up and
out the window through the
any slitting the curtains just in time
to see two of Ian's goons walking by
victim maybe a fifth and chestnut these
bad guys already have the street names
of Philadelphia memorized Holloway
idiots come on this guy is savvy enough
to memorize the streets of the city
instantly after arriving but dense
enough to leave his gun exposed in a
public farmer's market
gunfire in a public cemetery I know it's
silenced but it's also broad daylight
it's not a puffed up time filling chase
scene unless the bad guys can't shoot
first in a bottom the head of George
City Hall Jesus this evil henchman must
be from Philadelphia bad guys had no
problem shooting at him in a public
cemetery but a deserted public sidewalk
no way man asshole villain just happens
to be taking a stroll right around the
area and Michaela loses the tube let him
go but why you lost gates and while you
have the declaration you know you don't
have everything you need is there a door
that doesn't lead to prison
only in the movies Ben only in the
movies wait FBI guy helpfully shows
gates the hidden abilities of the
spectacles man this movie should be
called national ex machina until the FBI
agents listening in on this core bad guy
mentions he knows about the agents
listening in so we understand how smart
he is cliche obvious gun is actually a
static maker seems like the FBI would
know about such things and be able to
combat them but whatever plot must move
somehow well I guess the FBI just had to
let him go and consider him a non
suspect otherwise he would have been
free for ian's to kidnap things like
security locked doors and general
observations continue to elude public
places in this movie what you said Nova
hop me
you mean wide a museum archivists whom
you kidnapped during a heist never kiss
you after both you and her have been
kidnapped by evil people
they survive this trust me why you've
known him for like two days and pretty
much all he's done was lie cheat and
steal oh and kiss you damn the power of
female boners is stronger than I
realized
obviously not Nicolas Cage is actually
quite glad to be doing this stunt and
not having to step in during one of his
dangerous overacting scenes
unnecessary encouragement SIA back
somehow Ian decides that they're telling
the truth about Boston but doesn't take
the declaration or any of the items with
him just in case they might still be
handy to Ben yeah another curious thing
about Ian leaving is him not inspecting
the room thoroughly before taking off
this hike Lee was so obvious that they
would have never bought that bullshit
story about Boston despite the fact that
this treasure hunt has been a true test
of patience Ben looks defeated
immediately as if there's no way these
freemason assholes were once again
throwing it another obstacle in the way
of finding the treasure really thought I
was gonna find the treasure who he
thinks we're gonna buy this fake out
there is no treasure bullsh Oh see
that's what happens when you don't
inspect a room at all and just give up
immediately also it sure was lucky that
Ian left Ben with the pipe seemingly
unimportant to the plot anymore it came
out of nowhere when Ian made his deal
with Ben and lo and behold it's
important again no one in Ben's treasure
hunting party is gasping commenting or
otherwise making excited noises that the
treasure is on the other side then finds
addition flammable liquid and lights it
on fire because there's no way there
could be any booby traps or anything
down here right I mean turned out he was
all right doing it and he discovered
this fancy lighting system but good he
just as easily a blown up you know the
Templars and the Freemasons believed
lead FBI guy just happens to be
connected to the Freemasons in a
surprise no one saw coming nowhere is
important to the plot someone's got to
go to prison well if you've got a
helicopter I think I can help with that
yeah this is our law enforcement works
totally you're the one who stole it but
as long as we have some kind of criminal
hanging around he was also planning to
steal it
we'll just arrest him and let you go
Ian's been smart and resourceful the
whole movie but decided to take this
trip without an ounce of research or
thought wait Sean Bean doesn't die in
this movie does he at least die in the
sequel cut you want kidnapping attempted
murder and trespassing on government
property
and for being a no-good dirty Brit also
Ben gates did at least do those things
also but we're looking the other way for
that guy because he's the protagonist
o-q movie they flew Ben all the way to
Boston with the FBI guys just so we
could have a satisfying victory savoring
moment over Ian they offered
10% you turn it down Riley we've been
over this it was too much movie tries
too hard to make us believe that nobody
got any money for this just so they can
give us a surprise reveal later that
they took 1% which is still a clue to
money what do you care
you got the girl true true new lovers
are almost always faces
I've wasted 20 years of my life
it's a riddle it's a mystery wrapped in
a riddle inside an enigma I hope it's
not from stem
dear mr. good they call the right my
friend this will be the last packets I
ever send your ass support
it is surrounded by guards and video
monitors and little family from RIT a
system detects any increase in
temperature even the body heat of an
unauthorized person in the room will
trigger it if the temperature rises just
a single degree now inside the black
vault there are three systems operating
whenever the technician is out of the
room third system is on the floor and is
pressure sensitive and bring those
glasses you found its independence for
still trying to butch up by chewing on
your glasses on this gentleman as they
say is where the plot thickens now I'm
supposed to believe that
and tell the FBI agents listening in on
this call who from the FBI is in the van
I wonder let's see almost certainty
cross come on I do say hello hello
oh it's a secret evinces a design to
reduce them under absolute despotism it
is their right it is their duty to throw
off such government and provide new
guards for their future security
nerd I do a bunch of guys with hanging
tools build all this so they about the
pyramids yeah
the aliens help them
kampala family and friends lists closest
relative first
boy decide never happened to me get
positive IDs search everyone including
the security staff they refused take the
but if you're gonna smash their nosey
jumps from right to the floor everyone
jumps he falls down screaming blood
squirts out of his nose
ma-ma-ma-ma-ma